it's like a very very small proportion
of people are responsible for the vast
majority of the abuse racism expressions
heat online I think I saw something like
it's like 1% of Internet users are
responsible for it was either eighty or
ninety percent is that consistent with
your experience and what you've seen the
challenge though andrew is toxicity is
viral and what I mean by that is if I'm
if I'm an [ __ ] to you they'll
likelihood that you go and have a toxic
interaction in in the next session where
you're all in that platform goes up by
300% so wow it does stem from a it's not
really a small pool of users at this
point but like even 1% of interview
internet users what happens is it's then
viral and amplifies and and spreads
really rapidly through those communities
[Music]
hello everyone this is a crown man I was
Andrew Yang's campaign manager and now
the co-host of Yang speaks with Andrew
on today's episode we talked about the
Facebook boycott and what's going on
there we also bring on this guy who's
fascinating his name is John Redgrave
and he's an entrepreneur who's built
this AI technology that identifies hate
speech online to fascinating
conversation extremely relevant right
now so tune in hope you guys enjoy well
this week on yang speaks we're gonna
talk about the Facebook boycott what is
going on you might have seen a headline
about this thing and thought wow what
did Facebook do what and what do we want
from them so I gotta say this Facebook
boycott has now gathered up some of the
biggest brands in America in the world
really coca-cola Unilever Starbucks and
Patagonia and North Face like there are
a lot of huge brands that have said they
are not going to advertise on Facebook
for the month of July and this is big
news and I have to say I fully support
this effort I think it's pretty
phenomenal and the genesis of this was
not the advertisers themselves it's not
like coke woke up one day and was like
you know what like let's give Facebook a
hard time so as usual there were some
other people that were working behind
the scenes trying to make this happen
and in this case it was the
n-double-a-cp the anti-defamation league
ADL which is anti hate generally you
know that we tend to think of them as
being anti anti-semitism I suppose if
that's like can you say anti
anti-semitism making sets and Color of
Change the campaign's called stop hate
for profit and what they're asking
Facebook to do is to
change their ways in terms of how they
police and monitor and enforce bans
against hate speech on their platform
it's I was looking in this in this
Andrew and it really is I was like I was
thinking what is the impact of people
not advertising on Facebook and the
reality is Facebook is advertising today
you know they make 70 billion a year in
ad revenue but there's no way to sell a
product right now on any sort of scale
or hyper focus without using Facebook
and it's one of the reasons why I think
a lot of people have problems with them
because they don't need to listen to
anyone they are advertising they are
marketing and even these companies
they're all these massive brands are
only a small percentage of their entire
business which is crazy to think about
yeah it the numbers are really
interesting where if you look at the top
100 brands they accounted for 4.2
billion in facebook advertising last
year which sounds like a truck ton but
you're talking about a company that
makes 70 billion a year so 4.2 is you
know maybe five or six percent of the
total and it's not like all hundred
brands are turning it off for a year you
have maximally you know these brands are
turning it off for a month so this is a
significant dent but it's not
threatening like the core business of
Facebook to the point where they're
going to be having cash shortfalls in
part because of the universe of
advertisers like you just said Zach
because I remember when I ran a company
if you wanted to reach consumers you had
to advertise on Facebook that there were
like the granddaddy's of ways to reach
people it was Facebook and it's
Instagram affiliate and then you had
Google and that's where a lot of your
money was going and we were not a major
brand we were a relatively small company
so the reason why so much of the revenue
is
dependent upon the major brands is you
have every small to medium-sized
business in the country that has any
degree of internet savviness putting ads
on Facebook right and so that the issues
there's so many companies that literally
can't afford to not advertise on
Facebook because they're get generating
the vast majority if not all of their
business from Facebook so I do applaud
it is a big deal that the companies that
can't afford to not advertise on
Facebook are doing so I think that's
important so it's more of it's not just
symbolic it's you've got the best
American brands we have saying like
Facebook this is wrong and that is a big
deal they're good they can add a lot
more power even though they're a small
percent of revenue they've got a lot
more power collectively I think then
these mom-and-pop shops trying to throw
their weight around this is absolutely
terrible for Facebook's Brandon imagine
being a company and having every major
brand being like yeah no no to
advertising I mean if this happened to a
TV show or personality like this person
would have to be you know probably
thrown off the air like if every Brad
was like no thank you
so I don't want to understate the power
of this boycott i I think it's one of
the most significant efforts I've seen
in modern life that I can recall and so
the first question I think people might
be asking is like what did Facebook do
what did they do to deserve yes what's
the issue what's the issue and a lot of
it isn't so much what they did is what
they didn't do like yeah they just look
me up being like well first what they
didn't do is they didn't actually take a
hard-line stance against a lot of
content on the network or sources of
misinformation or in some cases really
rancid rendus messages and so if you are
a high level advertiser you're like a
Coke or Starbucks you don't want your
high level product and brand associated
with something sketchy so that's like a
concern that some of these advertisers
are leveling but Facebook
has number one taken a very very
hands-off approach to just about
anything on their site and so that
that's a very legitimate concern that
both civil rights activist groups and
advertisers would have and then number
two what they have not done is they have
not been transparent at all about their
own operations or standards whenever
someone comes and criticizes them about
what they're doing or not doing
they just say essentially trust us we're
working on it and there was a and there
was a period when that actually worked
pretty well for them because yeah the
Facebook brand was pretty positive big
text brand was pretty positive people
just associated them with innovation and
ease and modernity and there was this
instinct well that Facebook knows better
than the government Facebook knows
better than the regulator's Facebook so
when they said trust us it actually like
worked for a while but now people are
like wait a minute do we trust you like
what's really going on over there what
have you done to earn that trust yeah
yeah it's like well let's see you know
did Russians interfere with our election
last time with your you know at a
minimum like not safeguarding against it
was there Cambridge analytical hack of
millions of users that where there might
have been others that we just don't know
about like that one was publicized are
you making tens of billions of dollars
off of our data and we're not seeing a
dime like like these things are all true
and so now everyone's looking at
Facebook and saying actually we don't
trust you and and and this is the
situation Facebook is in it's
unprecedented in their history now they
have had a very poor track record of
genuinely opening up their practices and
coming clean and being subject outside
scrutiny they're frankly just terrible
at it like this is and someone talked
about how Facebook is less a company
than a country or a civilization I think
it was I was talking to so here in most
countries aren't thing oh that they have
2.2 billion users so that's way bigger
than any country
so they're joking like it's emperor
zotkin is 2.2 billion subjects and and
so so that they are really legitimately
terrible at at saying like yes here's
what we did wrong and you can check it
out and you know we need help with this
like they genuinely think that they are
bigger and smarter and better than
anyone else in the world and if you
criticize them their instinct is just to
deflect and and you know like put out
cryptic communications being like we're
working on and we're looking at it so
there's a legitimate cultural problem
that we can all see that they don't feel
themselves truly to be subject to much
of anything from the outside world and
Facebook has been saying correct me if
I'm wrong but face was generally been
arguing we are a marketplace for ideas
we're a platform for ideas and that
users are users generate things and we
just exist we have no say in put into
what goes on there and so therefore when
there's terrible things on there or
super positive things we just hands-off
is that and now we're at the point where
like that's not cool that's that's now
we've got let's now become problematic
am I getting that right yeah that that
is right they say we're not a publisher
we're a platform and as a platform we
don't have responsibility or
accountability for anything that people
say on our platform the way that for
example a magazine or TV network would
have like standards and then they
approach banning or restricting
communication on their quote unquote
platform as like oh that would be
censorship we're just like open forum
and then let everyone do what what they
want now that to me is a very convenient
stands for them to take but but it also
but but it's it's not matching up to
reality because we have to
acknowledge that Facebook at this point
is the biggest publisher in the history
of the world like saying that we're not
a publisher like your entire thing is
content and advertising like you're
making seventy billion bucks on ads like
you know but what that really seems like
to me it's like but is a publishing
Empire or media Empire because you know
how a lot of these media companies make
money also on advertising so if if we
hold them to certain standards it seems
strange for Facebook which is bigger and
richer than all of the other media
companies combined to somehow say like
no we have less responsibility all of
these other companies and this is a way
for them to really maximize their
revenue and profitability you know would
be one thing if Facebook were making
decisions where it was like oh this is
actually like against our interests
there was a Facebook investor who
characterized it as like Facebook just
hates friction it just wants to grow and
it sees everything that you are throwing
in its way as friction this boycott like
how do we get rid of this friction
that's like they're so and you know
restrictions on content like that would
be friction like they're just trying to
be as frictionless as possible
and but you know that worked during a
growth phase of a scrappy startup kind
of but at this point you're the you know
potentially the biggest most influential
company in the world you know you need
to have some kind of different approach
and evolution and responsibility right
so what are the advertisers and civil
rights organizations asking Facebook to
do so I found this to be fascinating I
was like ooh what I like the demands
like how do we know if this boycott
won't actually pull this up yeah it's
like what do they try to accomplish here
and so there's a whole list of demands
that there are about ten of them I will
go through some of the bigger ones
because some of them are related to each
other so this one I thought was very
very important submit to regular
third-party independent audits of
of identity-based hatin misinformation
with summary results published on a
publicly accessible website because
facebook again is a black box and
they're just like hey we got it like our
stuff says it's good so the the boycott
is calling for someone else to actually
post the data in a way that's not
completely subject to Facebook's own
internal reporting I think that is
perfectly reasonable I think providing
not this similar providing an audit of
and refund to advertisers whose ads were
shown next to content that were that was
later removed for violations of Terms of
Service I mean heck if you removed
content and I was the advertiser and I
was next to that I would not want to
have paid for that so seriously I mean
there's some really bad fails on there
where it's like you know like shared
most wholesome charities in the world
advertising next to discriminatory paid
groups you know Facebook whatever anyway
that's an easy one and fair in any other
business by the way
the next demand remove public and
private groups focused on anti-semitism
violent conspiracies Holocaust denial
ISM climate denial ISM white supremacy
yeah you know that there's another piece
around this that ensure accuracy and
political and voting matters by
eliminating the political exemption
which is something around there
disavowal of being able to verify
whether or not political ad is true or
false and this to me is both
common-sense and irresponsible because
cable networks say that they have to
verify whether a political ad was true
or false before they broadcast it but
Facebook's like who's to know we should
let the voters decide right it's like
like a voter has the time to figure out
whether some Facebook ad served up to
them was [ __ ] or not so Facebook is
clearly grappling with what to do about
political ads they recently made an
announcement saying we could all turn
off political ads if we wanted to on our
Facebook page now I'm sure that that
setting will be buried
somewhere like like I would be thrilled
if it was a giant button saying like you
want to turn off political ads because I
think a lot of people would click that
button and to me having political ads on
Facebook if you're gonna have them you
need to verify that they're not nonsense
and misinformation and the rest of it
particularly given that we know there
are foreign actors that have been
interfering in our elections so you need
to actually have take some
responsibility having voters have the
ability to turn it off highly
interesting I like it you know it's it's
an individual autonomy and if I don't
want to see clip clouds get it turned
off saying to Facebook hey no political
ads at all on the platform highly
interesting I wouldn't mind that either
you could make Facebook uh politics free
zone and clearly you're edging in that
direction a tiny bit if you're letting
people turn it off themselves
[Music]
okay this episode of Yanks Peaks is
brought to you by outer known and I can
comfortably say this is one of the most
comfortable clothing brands I've ever
owned and I think you agree Andrew yeah
that there they feel great they look
great you know that they were not made
by like miserable Bangladeshi kids who
are getting their knuckles broken or
whatever like that they're made in the
right way and a sustainable fashion so
you feel good about them yeah like I I
love my I don't know enclose I got to
say like they sent them some over and I
was like ooh and then I bought some with
this discount code I'm about to give you
all now I've been enjoying it it's made
by Kelly Slater you know what it is
Kelly Slater I was like an 11-time world
champion surfer like I feel cooler in
these clothes because I feel like a
little bit more of a surfer with ya
would make me a total poser because I
can't surf worth a damn but it makes me
feel a little bit more like a
professional surfer you could more like
you could surf yeah and that no one
would just like you know like yell you
off the beach or something so go to Erin
own calm today and enter my code yang at
checkout get 25% off your full price
order that's a Dern own calm oh you ter
que ando wnd.com and use my code yang at
checkout for 25% off check them out
today I don't own comm don't forget
promo code yang and yeah enjoy your new
clothes worth it worth it
[Music]
let me ask you this this is a
conservative in me asking when people
hear if the general Republican angle on
this is I'm here we're gonna ban the
hate speech we're going to ban false
information things like that how do you
how does the organization as Facebook
how does this regulatory organization
define hate and define what's right or
wrong here cuz I up to me there's some
obvious ones right where it's there's
clearly back science people denying the
Holocaust existed things like that seems
obvious but the fear that I think a lot
of conservatives have is that this
starts to go to a place where if I just
don't agree with your position I can
filter it I can mark it as spam I can
kick it off the platform what are your
thoughts on and this is what kind of way
you talk about John to on this podcast
is how do you what are your thoughts on
how you quote-unquote regulate the hate
now so there's their request here with
this boycott is to create expert teams
to review submissions of hate
nourishment so so this is something that
you need some kind of tribunal or
committee on and then they make a
decision then we can see what kind of
decision they make and I don't disagree
that this seems sticky where you're like
oh no like who the heck is gonna decide
what's off-limits and what's appropriate
because principled disagreement totally
appropriate like people saying like hey
like I actually have this very very
different point of view on it fine but
then when you start having right you
know like revisionist history like about
the Holocaust or something else that's
like a historical event like that ends
up feeding into very dark ideologies and
so you can't say well we don't have the
ability to draw any lines because then
you wind up with some really evil awful
stuff and Facebook hasn't even taken
that stance I I agree I think the way
you would do this andrew is you'd have
to have a as unbiased as you possibly
could board of reasonable people from
both sides the aisle right or various
different idea
and backgrounds and ethnicities and
experiences so you could come to terms
with either reasonable rules or
reasonable arbitration or ever that what
however that works and I realize that's
hard to me what bothers me is yes this
is hard and challenging maybe cost a
little money but Facebook you're making
seventy billion dollars a year you have
infinity money you like the excuse that
we need to grow and that profitability
at all costs doesn't make any sense ago
it's true they almost have a money
machine over there they're like just
print it some toddlers yeah like this
isn't fair anymore did they
profitability overall like come on
you're injured yeah so so someone
compares this to negative externalities
where if you had a chemical company or a
manufacturing company in the 20th
century and there was a period where
they just dumped [ __ ] in the river
because they'd be like whatever and then
eventually I looked up and we're like
hey you really should not be dumping
your waste products in the river we need
rules around that there's something
similar going out with Facebook where
they're almost like these psychic waste
products that are can I put two it's
like they're like printing but Giulia's
of dollars but it's like hey you know
what suffering our democracy our mental
health our ability to distinguish fact
from fiction our ability to communicate
with each other our ability to trust
anything like like these are the
negative externalities of some of
Facebook's practices and Facebook is
attributing essentially zero or near
zero consequence to these things they're
looking at them being like a like you
know yeah like I hear you chirping about
these things and I will try and get you
to shut up as expediently as possible
because I really don't genuinely care
about anything you're saying it's like
it's like really the message everyone is
beginning for a long time and so no so
now you literally have like the biggest
brands in the world lining up being like
Facebook please please like you know
take this seriously start like listening
to some of these people that want you to
get your acts together and grow up as a
company and one of the most encouraging
things about this is that there are
people in facebook that are saying the
same thing that like faith that people
at Facebook are like I work here and I'm
feeling less and less good about it
because everyone's starting to hate us
and they can tell that we're not
actually trying to solve any of these
problems in a serious way now what I
know about the Facebook organization
from like if I'm gonna you know like
outside looking in because oh who the
heck knows but it's it's a very very
top-heavy organization in the sense that
a lot of the power resides with mark and
Sheryl and and if you look at even like
the cap the capitalization structure
like the Voting Rights it's really mark
like you know yeah like marks got the
ability to override everything under the
Sun so so when we talk about all of
these things like it there's almost one
human being that matters in so far as
practices significantly changing and is
his name is Mark Zuckerberg like that
the fact that there are other people on
Facebook now that are trying to agitate
for this is very very powerful because
you know from what I've heard about the
workings of Facebook organization is
they do not like people being pissed off
and unhappy within their ranks like that
they consider themselves like a fairly
you know harmonious org and you know the
last thing you want is friction from
within it's like but but it's but it's
not the kind of thing where you know
it's not realistic for them to be like
your source of friction get out because
like they're like you know apparently
dozens or hundreds of employees who are
voicing some of the same concerns so I
am cautiously optimistic that we are
reaching a really unprecedented point in
Facebook's history where we might see
some genuine change and genuine reform
they're gonna do something in response
to this whether it goes as far as the
list of requested reforms
I don't know certainly their history
would make you think that it will not go
anywhere near that far but if anything's
gonna make it happen it's this
time this era and congratulations to the
activists and leaders who've made this
boycott so powerful it's it's awesome
again I'm not sure I can remember
something like this happening it's so in
I was a public policy major and there's
something called a collective action
failure
I don't you learn this but it's but it's
like it's like when you have a park
right and everybody everybody loves a
great open beautiful park but there's
always a couple [ __ ] that will go in
and leave some trash or park their car
on it or blast music on it
and if one or two people do that it's
not the end of the world but when
everyone does it it becomes a mess or if
no one's cleaning it up it hurts
everybody and the value of it starts
going down and that to me feels like
what's sort of happening with Facebook
where like everybody likes the idea of
connecting the world and having a
platform to share anything is that find
anyone anywhere but we've now gotten a
point where there's so much mess and
no-one's cleaning it up and the bigger
problem Andrew is that there's no other
park to play in this is the only one and
so I'll give credit oh and and when
another Park was forming this Park
bought that Park and they messed that
one up too and so we're all stuck in
this like shit-filled Park and we're
begging someone to just clean it up and
we don't even want like an epic amount
of cleaning we just want the basics done
like these demands are so freakin
reasonable that's what like to hit me so
hard like they're not doing any of this
so you know I hope this to your point
like besides massive government
intervention this is probably the only
other way you could do it you really
have to reflect on the fact we've gotten
to this point you know so the
government's been completely out to
lunch Facebook has been doing its thing
growing like a giant Jack in the
Beanstalk type operation like you know
like overtaking the world and now we're
at a point where literally it's like
coca-cola and Starbucks and Pepsi and
Unilever and Ben and Jerry's and
Patagonia like standing up for us
that for a second
like that's how the people clorox the
champion the people like that's what's
happening right now
yeah in part it in part because our
government is just so behind the curve
on these issues like there was a pair
there's worshipped technology and they
don't understand it you know I mean it's
one of my goals is going to be to try
and speed government up on these issues
certainly the data dividend project that
we announced last week is part of this
like we should own and benefit from our
own data and so if you have not signed
up for your data dividend go to DDP for
all calm and get that done July 1
actually the CCPA gotta is in effect in
terms of enforcement and we have some
exciting announcements on that side so
that's one big part of it but this
maturity that we're asking Facebook to
demonstrate in terms of how it deals
with its content and political ads and
other things is so important it's so
central and kudos to the people who've
led this particular charge certainly I'm
very supportive of it
and I hope that the people in Facebook
who listen to this like you are very
very powerful you know you're like ten
thousand times more powerful than anyone
outside of Facebook because we know that
Facebook leadership and Mark Zuckerberg
listen to you more they listen to anyone
else and yeah so keep pushing and let's
try and get Facebook to live up to its
responsibilities as one of the biggest
and most powerful companies in human
history john has literally started AI
that I hope a Facebook or live tech
companies start using to help meet some
of these demands I get that right yeah
so John is the the CEO of his brand-new
tech company co-founder and CEO of
Sentra P which has a product to identify
the hate speech and in on any platform
so you could use it not just on Facebook
but
you can use it on your corporate
intranet you could use it on other
social media platforms and it's a really
interesting discussion it's really
interesting problem you know I know when
you hear this you might think oh gosh
this sounds awful
like as who the hell wants software
looking at the [ __ ] that I type none of
us really truly I mean I understand like
that none of us want that but if you
look system-wide and society-wide like
do you need some kind of tools and
infrastructure because after that it
falls literally on that the head of some
miserable underpaid human being
generally a contractor who's supposed to
read it and and see that it's you know
acceptable or unacceptable or most
likely in most forums it just goes
completely untouched and ninety-nine
point eight percent of the time that is
completely fine because we're reasonable
people and the rest of it but then some
small fraction of the time it's toxic
and it can even become damaging and
dangerous and destructive and the way
that these internet networks work is
that a little bit of poison goes a long
way
it's like like if you've ever looked at
you know let's say like like you get 100
emails a day and I just had one of them
every other day that's like I'm gonna
kill you something like really [ __ ]
terrible and you know be like oh my
emails were 99.5% acceptable it's like
all you're gonna focus on is the one
person that that's sending some kind of
like crazy message you know so so that's
the problem that we're facing on a lot
of these platforms is a little bit of
crazy unfortunately it goes a long way
and so how do you identify the folks who
are not there for any reasonable purpose
except to spread hate or harass people
or harm people in some way so that's the
problem that Jon Redgrave is trying to
solve he's a really really savvy
experienced guy who's the
CEO of another company that was bought
by Apple and artificial intelligence
learned a lot from him about how his
company is trying to solve this problem
[Music]
[Music]
very happy to welcome to yang speaks the
co-founder and CEO of Sentra P serial
entrepreneur investor AI guru Jon
Redgrave he sounds like a fictional
British Lord welcome to yang speaks John
thanks for having me Andrew I really
appreciate it it's nice to be part of
the yang gang I'm really humbled by the
opportunity to chat with you this
afternoon I am so excited to sit down
with you because you're working on
something that might help us get out of
this mess that we're in and you've been
working on it for years so if you could
share a bit about your background and
how you came to be working on AI
detection of hate speech which is what
we're going to get into I was fortunate
enough to be introduced to two computer
science professors both geniuses in
their own right chris ray and mike
kaffir Ella are their names Chris he won
a MacArthur Genius award and so it
literally joining these geniuses we were
doing the most cutting-edge AI work
where we were essentially teaching
machines how to read with human levels
of context Wow the most important work
we did at the company was with DARPA and
we were working with DARPA through the
Memex program and in that we were
fighting human trafficking and so in the
human trafficking domain and this leads
into my central piece story so I'll get
there but in the human trafficking
domain what's really problematic is when
a human trafficking ring is broken up
all of the language and the patterns of
behavior changes right so you have this
adaptive adversary problem and because
you have that problem you need really
advanced technology that can understand
linguistic evolution all right so it's
I'm making it sound maybe more
complicated than well it is fairly
complicated from a computational
perspective but at the end of the day we
are figuring out how language changed so
they communicate in code and DARPA is
trying to figure out what the heck
they're talking about and how to detect
what they're saying they switch the
codes all the time because they don't
want to get caught is that is that
you nailed it so this is a problem
one the human trafficking problem has
been one that's you know frankly existed
for you know our nearly our entirety as
human beings but you know the the people
who are perpetrating human trafficking
have gotten much smarter and and so when
a human trafficking ring would get
broken up all of a sudden the patterns
would change so phone numbers that are
properly formatted with parentheses
three numbers - four numbers would
change into leet-speak
which is the the combination of changing
numbers into alphanumeric symbols right
or patterns so like the classic one that
most people know is changing the number
three into an e for instance right so
you'd start to see this leet-speak be
introduced new combina combinations
people would write out the numbers but
the most interesting pattern that we saw
was when dollar denominations started to
shift into flower varietals so literally
instead of saying this will cost you a
thousand dollars they would say this is
going to cost you a thousand you know
two nations yeah exactly two hundred
nations and and being able to pick that
up as a human being
it who studies it is actually not that
hard but to train a machine to do it is
really hard
so then you got absorbed into Apple and
then now you're back at it where you
have co-founded a new company that is
taking some of the expertise that Linus
developed and taking on a whole new
problem that right now is very very
central to our current struggles yeah I
mean look the the rama the psychological
and mental health ramifications right
like when you think about you know III
did a little digging you know and
thought about your mental mental health
and wellness part of your scorecard it's
like this is a fundamental aspect of
that right so you know I'll give you a
couple data points right so thirty
percent of adults in the US have some
have experienced severe online
harassment when you apply that to kids
it's
60% right and the / and so the the
challenge is that the story about your
friends is not unique like that's that's
our that's our state of affairs that's
the new normal yeah the indicators are
terrible I mean we have a mental health
crisis right now in this country and
that was pre pandemic and the pandemic
has by objective measurements something
like either tripled or tent up 'old like
the mental health problems in this
country then the number of parents who
report extreme stress think when
something from like two percent to
thirty seven percent and as a parent you
know you and I can understand why why
they'd be feeling that way incidents of
self-harm crisis text line use has
doubled it tripled and it's particularly
bad for young people and to me like
we're really losing the thread it's like
if our people are this anxious and
depressed and sick if our kids are
struggling to this degree like what the
hell are we doing like what's the point
of anything we're doing if you look up
and you see your children suffering yeah
I mean look this is about you know
making both our physical world and our
digital world better because for our
kids the the manifestation of their
physical self and digital self will be
one in the same I would argue and I
think that that requires us to reflect
upon not only what's happening in you
know the physical part of society but
also the digital part of our society and
as I reflect on everything that's
happened in the past three weeks in
particular I you know I'm very much in
support of black lives matter I stand
behind black lives matter and I really
hope that this creates change but when I
when I think about you know a role that
I potentially can play you know the
physical world is one that so much so
much focus was being applied to
rightfully so but the digital world is
just we're losing we're really losing
we've been losing that for a long time
we have yeah I mean I you know you're I
think we're both old enough to remember
the well the well was I think the first
online forum and the founders of the
well interest room he came
with a book and they talked about the
struggles with moderation and harassment
and abuse in their community because as
soon as they introduced anonymity all of
a sudden all hell broke loose
right you saw you saw kind of the worst
behaviors of humanity because everybody
was behind the veil of their the
keyboard in the screen it'd be
particularly bad for kids you know I
remember when I was a nerdy Asian kid
growing up I'd have a hard day at school
at least I could close the door and be
alone you know like today you close the
door and the kids are still right there
with you with the because you pull up
the smartphone and see them all you know
online and not even them just like these
idealized versions of them or these
vicious versions of them yeah I mean
that and I've talked to my niece and
nephew who are older about this and they
have days where they don't want to pick
up their phone because they're worried
about what they're gonna have to look at
and you know I think as I consider this
problem space and I I had a couple other
things that really impacted me so you
know one two of my best friends in San
Francisco went to Marjory Stoneman
Douglas on the school in Florida that
suffered a mass casualty event and then
a very close family friend of ours on
who I grew up with as well on he his
wife was shot 15 times in a mass
shooting in Cincinnati and survived and
you know when we so these are terrible
events unequivocally terrible events but
when you look at what perpetrator you
know the perpetrators were doing in and
how they got in these echo chambers a
lot of it was they were getting red
pillows online right and so I just I
felt called frankly to come out and and
try to make a difference when it came to
abuse online because if we don't solve
abuse online then you know I think we
continue to lose this battle long term
around
well the online feeds into the offline
where you look at like the New Zealand
shooter you know who was very much
online in terms of their radical
and then their attempt to share the act
in real time I mean it's not just like
oh like you know people said and I mean
it radicalizes people it makes them
capable of inhuman tragic catastrophic
atrocities and so I'm really glad that
you're standing up to say look we can't
just turn a blind eye to this anymore
it's like feeding into the destruction
of our way of life but we had Jaron
Lanier onyang speaks not that long ago
and do you know Jaron I don't so so his
ideas to me are in some ways like a
necessary foundational layer for what
you're talking about so here's like the
the the I think very commonly held view
it's like look people are people people
are nasty online that sucks but you know
First Amendment free speech like what do
you really want to do like who's gonna
police this do you trust the government
to police this do you trust these firms
to police this so it's just kind of a
necessary evil and so that that's like a
basic point of view that a lot of people
have and then Jaron Lanier comes along
and says look there's something about
this digital Commons that enables
negative ideas and ideologies to spread
much more virulent ly and effectively
than in an offline world in an offline
world if you're someone who holds
terrible beliefs it's not that easy to
somehow like find other people that
we're gonna like hear you out you know
it's like what are you gonna do I go
into the town square and just be like
hey I hate these people I hate these you
know it's like it's really like it's not
that easy but online you can set up like
a convening place for your hateful
beliefs or ideologies or conspiracy
theories and then people who are adrift
and lost can like find their way to it
and wind up going down these very deep
rabbit holes around other people who
will incite them
towards hatred and there was a joke
about how on YouTube you're always like
three clicks away from alex jones or
whatnot
we're like these conspiracy theories are
very high engagement and so you you wind
up and they get fed to you by some of
these algorithms because they're high
engagement and so you could just be that
they're like you know watching movie
trailers or whatever and then before you
know it like a little while later you're
like what's going on there's like some
some crazy conspiracy theory so if you
look at the mechanics of these digital
networks and and the internet they end
up giving rise to much net more negative
and destructive behaviors and ideologies
then was previously possible and then
that's where we are right now is like
everyone's looking around being like
what the [ __ ] do we do because the
government that seems way asleep at the
switch on this stuff like that you know
it's like they haven't had a serious
look in at technology in 25 years you
know like looking around being like what
like there was a period where like
technologies like just like they're
beyond government like reproach because
we're just too dumb and behind and then
you look at the technology firms and you
have companies like facebook that are
looking up being like not responsible
for anything that goes on like will have
some content moderator moderators who
lose their minds to staring at the worst
of humanity for weeks on end and then
they sue us because they were
contractors and it turns out we
traumatized like you know hundreds of
them so we'll quietly pay the millions
of dollars and then just do it again so
that is like the current world we're in
right now i just want to set that up for
you just in the sense that you know
because because i'm sure people have
like a native resistance to anyone
trying to curb any kind of behavior
online yeah i mean you know the the
people who contend that you know well
this is how it is and this is how it's
going to be um like let's let's take an
extreme example let's talk about
racism like okay well if we if we aren't
bucking the status quo on racism like is
that are we going to accept that status
quo or not right and and I think this is
a moment where it's not only on us as
individuals to take a stand but also you
know frankly the tech companies to take
a stand like their work they are you
know the leaders of the biggest tech
companies the world their metal is being
tested right now and it's going to be
really interesting to see who's willing
to stand up to the abuses that are
rampant on their platform and who isn't
right and what does that mean for their
not only for you know them as human
beings
but but really what does it mean for
them as companies right because you're
right I mean the the biggest platforms
are the places where a lot of this
content is is concentrated and it's not
you know people think oh it's 4chan and
8chan and some of these offshoots it's
not I mean this is on the Main Street of
the Internet at this point and wow it
spreads from some of the more toxic
corners like 14 mm-hm you know Facebook
Twitter reddit discord you know others
all all have challenges that they need
to step up to and and frankly that's why
we built our company because your point
about content moderation is a great one
I mean one the content moderation
industry is a multi-billion dollar
industry now propped up by people who
are having to you know look at the worst
of humanity on a daily basis with
terrible tools not very sophisticated
technology and you know frankly he end
up in large and in huge numbers with
PTSD like who wouldn't wind up with PTSD
if you were just watching child porn and
beheading videos all day I mean you you
would lose your mind you know it's like
like they're trying to keep us all from
losing our minds but they're gonna lose
their minds yeah and so the big question
is all right well what can we do you
know one it's can we build better
technology and - can we get the
companies to
actually stand up right or or force them
to stand up and so you know Wow on I
think the the executive order around
Twitter was interesting like see dat 30
was the crux of that executive order
right so on CD a 230 has been around
since the 90s right it's a prodigy and
like this is a regulation that deserves
additional attention and scrutiny
deserves some modernization I mean what
the heck they passed this law in the 90s
when you know you're still lookin at
like you know do cities or whatnot yeah
we didn't have Facebook we didn't have
Google like none of these none of these
platforms existed when that regulation
was put into place and well I think the
regulation is incredibly important to be
clear because I you know I think that
the concept of well look let me boil it
down as a restaurant right if I owned a
restaurant I have the right to let
people into my restaurant or not right
so it's or like a up school or you know
a church right yet you have the right
from a from the point of free
association right to to let people in or
not and I think that's an important
principle that is applied by CDA to 30
to give companies the right to moderate
or not to moderate right and not be held
liable for that but I think it's really
challenging because there's such a large
array or diversity of what is required
of the companies to get that protection
right senator Wyden who put it into
place he constructed it as both a sword
and a shield right so the sword is you
can moderate what you want the shield is
you are not held liable for what's
posted on your site I think that's
incredibly important but you know to
have that same principle applied to
companies who are actually making an
earnest effort to moderate versus
companies who make zero effort to
moderate and let hate hate spread
rampantly
seems like I love that distinction yeah
it's like look if you're trying to do
the right thing and investing then you
know will not hold you liable but if
you're just like kind of just hand
waving at it that's saying like oh we're
protected like we can't do it it's too
hard it's like literally you're some of
the biggest richest country companies in
the world I mean I just said countries I
mean you might as well be a country yeah
like at this point you know Facebook
reaches 2.2 billion people I mean that's
bigger than any country and you know
it's it's valued at two-thirds of a
trillion dollars like you know it's got
tens ability one can invest the proper
resources in it it's them but instead of
leading in that direction they're just
like not our responsibility
if you just improve transparency
reporting on what's actually happening
in in general platform transparency that
would go a long way to change the
behavior of users right not only users
but also to say to the world hey we're
actually taking a stand here's what
we're removing here's why we're removing
things and and to be more clear and
consistent about why things are
happening right part of it is what are
the challenge is it just feels like the
Wild West right you go onto Twitter and
in the same day that you know someone
gets blocked for on you know one form of
abuse you can find that exact same form
of abuse in another pocket of Twitter
yeah
these these companies are playing
whack-a-mole and on one hand you you're
like okay I get it like you know there's
a lot of stuff you're after and I'm not
gonna like be too mad at you if you like
it you know if I mole popped up for a
little while but on the other hand
there's like so little rhyme or reason
to it we're like it's hard to have
confidence and it's also clear that this
isn't like a main priority for certain
of them in the way it should be like it
should be a much bigger priority than it
is yeah I think in a lot of ways this
has become existential for Facebook and
and to be fair you know you won't find
me defending Facebook very often but
they have incredibly good machine
learning talent like incredibly good and
so their ability to detect different
forms of abuse is better than anybody
else's like orders of magnitude better
in my opinion now
it this is the point though you can
detect it but are you gonna take a stand
against it right and so you get into
these policy arguments where people are
saying well you know maybe maybe we
should do this but people aren't taking
a data-informed approach instead they're
saying well here's the thing we're
getting beat over the head with in the
press so now we have to write a policy
against this like that
that feels haphazard to me I've always
been a believer that
if you can figure out what the data
looks like build your policies such that
you can impact the data in the way that
you want well well this is really the
thing that frustrates me and so many
people about Facebook it's like like
that their situation is like we're doing
our thing oh we've been publicly
criticized for this thing that came out
in the press like Cambridge analytic or
like some other flare-up and then
they're like oh snap
let's like say I'm so sorry we'll do
better and then come up with some policy
and then like someone internally ends up
you know dealing with it
so like here like the major problems of
this number one it's like we're not
really sure what's going on with you
posted like your policy implementation
because you're not transparent and and
two you have better data than us so like
why are you waiting for us till I get
mad at you about something that happened
in some cases like months and months ago
like why don't you just like look at
what's going on and then you can tell us
so you like you know like that that to
me is the frustration and it lets you
know - it's like it really is not the
priority it should be because they only
share information or make a policy
change after there's some kind of public
pressure
[Music]
[Applause]
today's episode of yang speaks is
brought to you by athletic greens which
is the all-in-one daily drink to support
better health and peak performance so
even with the balanced diet as it's
difficult to cover all your nutritional
bases and so athletic greens is this
daily drink
it's like nutritional insurance for your
body delivered straight to your door
it's this funky green powder that's
pretty awesome poured in some water
shake it up drink it tastes delicious
and it's got this complex blend about 75
vitamins minerals whole foods sourced
ingredients all this goodness to help
you get your veggies it's pretty great
if you're like me you do not have enough
veggies in your diet and then athletic
greens you like put it in a cup drink it
and you know you actually did what you
needed to do for that day if you're like
an efficiency fiend who I use they're
like oh I gotta get stuff done and this
makes you feel like you're getting stuff
done because you're being good to your
body it feels good yeah like you know
it's working you know you can tell it's
one of those things you drink in you're
like yeah this stuff is working so
whether you're looking to boost your
energy levels support your immune system
or address gut health now is the perfect
time to get athletic greens visit
athletic greens calm slash yang to claim
a special offer of 20 free daily travel
packs with your first purchase a $79
added value again that's athletic greens
dot-com slash yang its all-in-one
nutrition you drink it and it'll make
you feel better about yourself your day
and what you're doing long-term for your
health and the one thing I found out
that if you're doing like the keto thing
the paleo or you're vegan or dairy-free
you're gluten-free it checks all those
boxes it's pretty much everything free
you're good athletic greens calm
slashing
[Applause]
we hadn't investor as part of the
company on and she was recently harassed
on Twitter and what she had to do was
then go and block the users who harassed
her report those users and then as part
of you know Twitter's process she had to
go through and then look at other
content abusive content from that same
user to verify that this person is
actually abusive like when when did we
make the people who were the users of
our product the first line of defense
right like that just does it doesn't
make any sense and so you know what I'm
advocating for is one more transparency
better communication from these
companies about when they are taking
action and why they're taking action
which I think you know most social
psychologists who I've spoken with would
argue will have a positive reinforcement
loop where the people will actually want
to make platforms better because they
see that something action is being taken
or maybe they're in the wrong and
they'll change their behavior and then
when I'm really advocating for naturally
because I'm building a company to do
this is more robust detection and don't
you know take take the human out of the
line of fire as much as you can yeah so
so tell us about the technology you're
working on I know one of the the facets
of it is that you manage to almost build
like a taxonomy of abuse and hate speech
where you can pick up if someone is
being racist or abusive like through AI
and their use of particular language and
it's not just the obvious ones I mean
obviously like you know with someone
listening to this it's just like well
like duh like if you you know call
someone certain things like I could
figure that out but a lot of the times
it's much trickier than that
yeah I'm that's it's a beautiful tee up
frankly because we've just in the last
you know couple months seen a bunch of
examples of this but
the core of what we're building is a
natural language understanding system as
a starting point because in order to
solve this problem or to be able to at
least detect the nuance of this problem
you need to be able to understand the
context in which something is being said
so you and I were introduced Andrew
because my company had identified a huge
uptick in anti-asian racism as a results
of coronavirus right yeah so like in
this example what we are seeing is we're
seeing not only a huge uptick in the
normal terminology and so what most
people in kind of the machine learning
or data science space would call like a
bag of words so you start out you know
you have a dictionary of words that are
unequivocally bad that is oh I heard a
lot of those growing up unfortunately I
am I'm sorry to hear that you did it's
like that is pretty round
I'm just letting people know it's like
we all know what those were I mean like
the words that come to mind for me are
you know [ __ ] and [ __ ] so those like
the obvious ones but then it gets more
nuanced it gets much more nuanced
because what happens is a lot of like
the the current the current attack
vector for dealing with this problem is
oh let's just come up with the worst
words that people use and the standard
Spelling's of those worst words and will
block them right but there are a number
of problems that one you have an
adaptive adversary problem there are
people who are going to shift their
language and we've seen that the
language in online communities shifts
exponentially faster than it does
offline or in the physical world right
so number two is what happens when
people are trying to re-appropriate
terms you're gonna have a ton of false
positives right so you're gonna you're
gonna start flagging things totally
inappropriately on you know so like the
you know the N word being used in our /r
app or even in you know a place like
hashtag black lives matter right where
someone's trying to reappropriation
who's using it as a white
like those have very different
connotations obviously but if you can't
understand the context that's really
that's really impactful and it means
that your human reviewers who are likely
seeing this are having to look through a
bunch of content that they shouldn't and
they can't prioritize their cue the the
other so going back to the first point
though being able to understand the
adaptive adversary so I'll give you the
examples and you've seen some of these
because you saw our report on it and we
have a blog post now about it on our
medium account but during kovat we saw
this huge spike in terms like kung flu
on you know so anti sickness Winnie the
flu which went there's you know there's
adapt adaptation on Winnie the Pooh
which is used in reference to Tiananmen
Square on like you see all we actually
caught about eighty-five new terms that
had popped up over a four and a half
week period that are now a number of
which are being used in as a replacement
for the words that you referenced I'm
getting like I'm guessing there is
probably at least one that has a
reference as bats I'm guessing it would
be like yep exactly
yeah yeah like bad eater comes to mind
for me yeah I think I know a friend of
mine was called that yeah it's and this
is the you know so it's problematic not
only because it's on its reprehensible
behavior but it's also problematic
because norms are formed so rapidly in
online community so it's not only that
language shifts but the norms form
really quickly and so if you let this
content fester then all of a sudden
people go oh that's normal this is this
is something that you know people say
and regardless of whether you're an
adult who you know frankly should know
better in a lot of cases or you're
someone who is down the rabbit hole and
looking to reinforce their beliefs or
you're a young naive kid who just
frankly doesn't know better like it's
problematic in all the cases right
anyway let me give you a like a soy
slightly more disturbing although all
are disturbing example from the last
three weeks
so on after Ahmad Aubrey was killed and
then George Floyd was killed we saw an
uptick in the use of the term jogger as
a replacement for the n-word know it's
dark and disgusting but and you can see
it and so we we see this all over I mean
you you could run a search on Twitter
and a search on other major platforms
and you will find the use of that term
being used as that replacement like
that's really problematic and so what
we're doing is we're constantly keeping
tabs on some of the worst communities
online and then we're using algorithms
to tell us what's bad
based on how things are contextually
similar to other language and so that is
a huge step forward in terms of this
problem space because if you can keep up
with the language of the Internet you
actually might be able to address this
problem proactively and so you know I'll
give you one last stat there are a
thousand terms added to urban dictionary
a day that tells you how profound and
quickly you know like language is and
health how quickly it moves online now
one thing that I remember seeing which I
think that most people sense
instinctively it's like a very very
small proportion of people are
responsible for the vast majority of the
abuse racism expressions heat online I
think I saw something like it's like 1%
of Internet users are responsible for it
was either eighty or ninety percent is
that consistent with your experience and
what you've seen yeah it really depends
on the community to be fair but on the
major platforms that's definitely true
right the challenge though andrew is
toxicity is viral and what I mean by
that is if I'm if I'm an [ __ ] to you
they'll likelihood that you go and have
a toxic interaction
in in the next session where you're all
in that platform goes up by 300% so so
wow it does stem from a it's not really
a small pool of users at this point but
like even 1% of interview Internet users
what happens is it's then viral and
amplifies and and spreads really rapidly
through those communities every week we
read news stories or hear personal
anecdotes about people being harassed I
want to help these I want to help people
like at the end of the day I built this
company to help to help resolve systemic
abuse you know to end online abuse and
at the end of the day like if I helped a
bunch of individuals that's great
like I'd be very it is great right I I
love what you're doing because it's so
constructive and positive and concrete
and practical you know like you're in a
very rare and privileged position where
you may be able to actually make a
difference to huge numbers of people by
actually helping improve the machinery
which is beyond the capacity of the vast
vast majority of us and it's great for
people to get a sense that people like
you exist and that you're doing
something that may improve their lives
and their children's lives so if someone
wants to find out more about you and
your company it sounds like you have a
medium account is it sent repeat com yes
entropy comm is our website and you will
be able to get to our medium account
from there all right fantastic John
Redgrave founder and CEO of a company
that's going to make the future a little
bit brighter and better for all of us
congratulations man and best of luck
with the new company I know it's an
incredible journey when you unveil your
new enterprise to the public you've been
part of a couple of these ventures
before but you're you're taking a huge
stand it's so important and you're
fighting for all of us so thank you my
pleasure Andrew and thanks again for
having me on happy to be part of the
yangyang
yes yeah gaming game welcome John
[Music]